The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome
everyone, today.
Today we're going to be talking
about advanced concepts.
These are kind of
like what I would
consider the next
generation of solar cells
if these ideas pan out.
Some of them are very
near and dear to my heart
because it's what my research
is mainly focused on.
Also another quick
realization I had last week.
Probably Tonio mentioned
this to me at some point,
but do you guys know
where 626 comes from,
why the course is called that?
So 6.26 times 10 to the minus
34th is Planck's constant.
So haha, funny.
Thought that was kind of cool.
It's a little joke put in there.
So anyhow without further ado,
one of the cool things-- cells
are done.
Yay.
This is great news.
I was very, very happy.
So it didn't go quite
as well as expected.
I think most of
you are finding out
that these are incredibly
[INAUDIBLE] limited.
I'm going to talk about why
that might be in a second.
Hopefully that will
help you guide you
through your
analysis, which we'll
be doing for the final
part of the quiz 2.3,
which hopefully I'll be able to
post by tomorrow afternoon-ish.
I'm still working
on that right now.
But just to give you guys
kind of the processing
that you didn't get
to see, this is what
the contact firing looks like.
It's a very, very,
very fast process.
It's really remarkable
to me that this
combines so many
photlithographic steps
that if you wanted to
make this in the lab using
photlithography, and
condenses these six or seven
steps into one process.
So it's pretty remarkable.
So DuPont, the people who
made the pace-- so we used
PV16A if you guys are curious
for our front contacts
for silver paste.
And we actually get--
the really important part
is this peaking
temperature, and you
can see we actually got pretty
close to the ramp times.
Where it really starts
to deviate is here,
and we hold it around 400,
a little bit longer, which
is several reasons for that, and
I'll go into that in a second.
But what's important
is that all these are
fired in an oxygen atmosphere.
So normally in
these belt furnaces,
and this is again what's used
in industry-- this is actually
the same exact tool
that I use at Harvard--
it actually looks like this with
the giant CRT monitor on top.
The only way to get the data
off is with a three and a half
floppy drive.
I can't tell you
how difficult it
was to find a working three
and a half floppy drive.
Most of them are
demagnetized at this point.
I had to buy new ones.
They're still being
made, by the way.
If you want them, go to Staples.
So anyhow, it's done in
an oxygen atmosphere,
so they generally force airflow
into these giant belt furnaces,
and these are really long.
Like that's probably
about a foot
wide, maybe 18 inches wide.
So this goes on for tens
of feet, or several meters,
depending on where you're from.
And it's done an oxygen
atmosphere, an air atmosphere,
because it needs to burn
off a lot of the binders
and some of the organics
that might still be there.
And so those organics burn
off, and what you're left with
are the little metal particles,
the frit, and some metal oxide
glass.
It's usually lead oxide,
although DuPont will never
tell you, but from
papers I've read
this is generally what's used.
So when that happens-- this
is that burn-off period.
When it spikes, the
frit will actually
burn through your
silicon nitride layer.
You guys didn't have a
silicon nitride layer,
but if it was there, it
would help eat through it.
And so that way, you've
removed the dielectrics
so you can actually make metal
contact with your silicon
surface underneath.
That firing will-- during
that peak also simultaneously,
these middle particles
will melt and form
this triple eutectic point
with the silicon underneath it.
And so the triple comes from
the silver, the silicon,
and the lead.
The lead actually
dissociates from the glass.
This lowers the melting
temperature of that mixture,
and you can make good ohmic
contact with the surface.
So it's actually a pretty
remarkable, incredible process.
It's still almost
kind of magic to me
on how the whole thing
works, and a lot of it's
just kind of guess and check
and still very proprietary.
So the science is still
a little lacking there.
You don't find a lot of
good articles explaining
the science of it.
I have a few if you
guys are interested.
NREL's put out a lot of really
interesting stuff, and some
of the ways they
actually figure out
the actual profile underneath
the contacts versus you
measure the temperature on
the side of the contacts,
so actually touching the silicon
or the silicon nitride surface,
is you actually measure hydrogen
diffusion underneath it.
And so they'll actually
etch off the contacts
and using secondary ion
mass spectroscopy measure
the hydrogen concentration
off the contact
and underneath the contact,
and that'll actually
tell you what temperature it
saw based on that diffusion
profile.
So there is some good
science going on,
but there's not a lot
of great papers on it.
So anyhow, that just
kind of gives you
what I was working
on over the weekend,
trying to get these cells fired.
So I aggregated a
lot of the results
and tried to make sense
of what was going on.
I think I showed some of you
different firing temperatures
and the fill factors
that we got and there
was kind of just noisy data, so
I couldn't get any real trends.
The best trend I could
find was that if you
take the median of all
the short-circuit currents
of the cells and
you look at the ones
with four millimeter and
two millimeter spacing,
the four millimeter spacing
has a slightly higher
short-circuit
current, presumably
due to shading losses.
If you look at the relative
areas that each of these
cover up, you would
expect a 4% increase.
This is about 3%, so
I'll take that as fact.
It's certainly within
the noise and the error
of the number of
samples that we have,
but I thought it was
interesting nonetheless.
Additionally, I plotted
the series resistance
that I calculated from
your dark IV curves
and plotted your maximum power.
I also removed all the
cells that were broken.
I'm sure if I actually
normalized them--
some of the cells that
were broken actually
performed a lot better,
and I'll get into maybe why
that was the case in a second.
But really the
take-home message is
that our really best
performing cells are all
clumped over here.
And so you can see that our best
cells have a very low series
resistance.
That's not always the case.
There's some outliers,
like this guy here,
and I don't know
how that happened.
So some really interesting
things going on,
and I'm still trying
to sift through it.
So I talked about
this I think yesterday
in the analysis section,
but there's several sources
of series resistance.
Any of you guys familiar
with what they are?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] resistance
and emitter sheet resistance.
PROFESSOR: Emitter sheet
resistance, and then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there's line
resistance along the fingers
and then there's
contact resistance,
so I'm going to draw
this out really quickly.
So if you have--
this is your emitter.
You have a contact here
and a contact here.
If you generate an electron
here, it'll diffuse,
hit the junction.
Then it has to flow through
the emitter to the contact.
There's an associated
resistance with that.
That's the series
resistance that we
taught in class that has to do
with the emitter resistance.
Additionally to hop over that
metal semiconductor junction,
there's actually a
resistance there.
That's called a
contact resistance.
So this is emitter and
this is our contact,
and then it has to travel from
the line to the busbar here,
and that's our line resistance.
And I think what's
really limiting us,
because when I looked at both
the shallow and deep emitters,
the series resistance
didn't really
have any noticeable trends.
So I really think that this is
what's limiting us completely,
is our contact resistance,
which is kind of too bad.
So one of the reasons
I think that that's
the case additionally
is that the cells
that performed the best-- I know
Joel's did particularly well.
What was your fill factor?
Do you remember?
AUDIENCE: Well, on the one side
it was 0.5, and on the other
it was 0.64.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
one side was better.
So again, the inhomogeneity
of doing the measurement
is also another indication
that our series resistance
across the contacts
is really poor.
So some of the other
contacts if you look on the--
where's my good piece of chalk?
Right.
If here's our busbar, some
people saw delamination.
Who saw their
contacts delaminated?
Yeah, so a couple people.
And so what that means is
that these contacts actually
peeled up, and that's usually
showing that the-- what's
funny, though, is that
these areas in the middle
didn't delaminate.
It was only the edges
here, and so that's
showing that some parts
are being properly fired
and some parts are
being underfired
because when I fired
at higher temperatures,
I was getting shunting.
And that was due to shunting
through the center area.
So I think that the RTA
that I was using-- this
wasn't the case on some of the
earlier cells I had processed,
but is rather
inhomogeneous in terms
of the temperature profile
it's delivering to our cells.
So I think that could be
part of our problem, as well.
AUDIENCE: How many cells did
he fire up at the same time?
Just one, or--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's one at a time,
and there's some variability
in the peak firing temperature.
So I've learned a
lot about when we're
going to buy an RTA for
our lab, what to look for.
The temporal
resolution of the data
you get out of it and how it
records it is 0.6 seconds.
And when this thing's
ramping at 100 C per second,
your variability is quite large.
So the temperature I read is
not just from the data point,
but I do a linear interpolation
to actually figure out
what the peak is on
both sides of that peak,
and it ends up being about
anywhere from 20 to 40
degrees Celsius higher
using that technique.
And so the variability varies.
It's about 20
degrees plus or minus
10 degrees Celsius in terms
of what I want the peak to be
and what it actually is.
So the RTA that we're using now
is not incredibly reputable.
Also, better RTAs will
have a different heater
on top and bottom, and
so you can actually
heat one side more
than the other.
And generally belt furnaces,
so commercial ones,
will have that same
kind of control.
I know at 1366, they've
actually done optimization
to do heating the top
and bottom differently
because they use different
pace, they have different heat
requirements,
thermal requirements.
And so nailing that
temperature and that profile
actually takes a lot of
iteration and a lot of time.
And it's really just learning
the tell as opposed to,
the again, good
science behind it.
So it can be rather difficult
and time-consuming to do.
So that's what I have
to say about the cells.
I think overall, though, I
think the efficiencies are
on the order of 6% to I think
9% for some of the cells,
so that's not too bad.
I'm still rather
pleased with that.
Last time I think
Tonio stopped right
before he was going to talk
about performance of modules
in the field and kind
of what's the difference
between your cell efficiency
and your module efficiency.
Modules are put out in the sun.
They heat up.
They can get shaded by
snow, rain, clouds, trees,
and also the modulus are made
up of many different cells that
are connected in
series and parallel,
and how does that affect
their overall performance
of the module?
And so that's what we're going
to talk about really quickly.
So first off, why does
temperature matter?
So all solar cells when
they're measured either at NREL
or in our lab, are measured
under standard operating
conditions-- or standard
testing conditions, sorry.
Certainly not standard
operating conditions.
Standard testing conditions
are done at 25 C.
Generally the cells
are actively cooled
to maintain that temperature
of room temperature,
and most semiconductor
simulations you perform
are generally done
at 300 Kelvin.
I know all the calculations
I did for fitting
your [INAUDIBLE] diode
curve were done at 300
K. Typical operation can
actually be pretty hot,
so 50 to 65 degrees Celsius.
I actually don't know if that
is in Fahrenheit, but it's hot.
It's hotter than
Phoenix, and I'm
sure they get even
hotter in Phoenix.
So the effective temperature--
so how does it affect Voc?
If you recall, this
is our diad equation.
We have our
illumination current,
which we'll get to
how that's affected
by temperature in a second.
But for now, just ignore that.
Assume it stays constant.
So one of things that's
really affecting your Voc-- so
remember, your Voc is going
to make your current go to 0,
and the main thing
that's being altered
is your saturation current,
so your intrinsic carrier
concentration, your diffusivity.
So who here thinks
your Voc is going
to go up with temperature?
Anyone?
And who thinks it'll go down?
Who has no idea?
OK, so who raised their
hand for it'll go down?
Sorry.
Ben, do you have any ideas
why that might be the case?
AUDIENCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So what's
going to happen to your I0
with increased temperature?
AUDIENCE: The intrinsic
carrier concentration, ni,
is going to increase, and
that should increase I0?
PROFESSOR: That
should increase I0,
so therefore it's going to take
a smaller voltage to counteract
I sub L to make I equal to 0.
And so why does N sub I
increase with temperature?
AUDIENCE: Greater
thermal energy present
increases the film probability
that electrons can be
excited from the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right, so
it increases the number
of thermally-promoted carriers.
And so that effect can
actually be pretty stark,
and now we go to a demo.
Yay.
All right, so what we have here
is our favorite solar cell.
This came, again, from
those small little toy
cars that we pulled off, and
again, these solar cells,
the cars will
assume were nothing,
and these are about $10
apiece, so pretty cheap.
Probably cheaper than your
solar cells that you guys made.
And, well, certain I
know they are cheap.
The wafers themselves, by
the way, were $16 apiece,
so saying they were a dollar
was a little inaccurate.
So anyhow, we have this
hooked up to a multimeter
and we're going to measure
the voltage off of it.
I'm going to illuminate
it with our desk lamp,
and we can actually get
a pretty decent voltage.
I can't actually see this.
So it's about 0.57
volts, and now we're
going to subject
it to temperature.
This is obviously a
gross overestimation
of what's actually
going to happen,
but can someone read
off-- Joel, can you
read the temperature for me?
AUDIENCE: The temperature,
or the voltage?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, the voltage.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're at 0.561 and decreasing
down to 0.55, 0.54, 0.53--
PROFESSOR: So it's going down.
So congratulations
the people who
said it would go down, correct.
Wow, that's actually quite hot.
Anyhow, so that's what
happens in the field.
So when these cells heat up,
you actually lose on your Voc.
And if you really want to, you
can go through all the math.
You know what the
equation is for your Voc.
It's shown here, and you can
go through this if you like.
It's all on PVCDROM if you want
to go through the derivation.
You then can take the derivative
with respect to temperature.
And if you plug in values
for crystalline silicon,
it comes to about 2.2
millivolts per degree Celsius,
which sounds like
a small number,
but it's at around 0.1
volts if you go up to 65 C,
so that's actually quite
a substantial amount.
And again, when you're
going from 0.6 to 0.59,
these small margins can make or
break a lot of installations,
so that's an important one.
OK, now this one's
a little harder.
What do you think will
happen with your illumination
current, or your ISC?
Who thinks it's going to go up?
Anyone?
Who thinks it's
going to go down?
Who thinks it's going
to stay the same?
Who has absolutely no idea
and didn't raise their hand?
OK, that's totally fine.
This confused me,
as well, by the way.
So when we think about it, what
is our short-circuit current
proportional to generally?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so generally
your illumination intensity.
And what photons generally
are we collecting?
AUDIENCE: Super bandgap.
PROFESSOR: Super bandgap.
So what could be happening is
our bandgap could be changing.
I sub L, as Ben pointed
out, should increase
the flux of photons
above the bandgap,
and EG actually decreases
the temperature.
So your bandgap actually
usually increases--
the true bandgap of
silicon defined--
most properties
of semiconductors
are actually
defined at 0 Kelvin,
and semiconductors
are technically
insulators because they
don't conduct electricity
at 0 Kelvin.
That just means semiconductor
is a class of materials
that have a small enough bandgap
that they can thermally promote
carriers that they can actually
conduct some electricity
at room temperature.
But the true bandgap of
silicon's around 1.17.
And as you increase
temperature, you
get a reduction of the bandgap.
And so what should happen
is your ISC should increase,
but only very, very slightly.
So if you go over the derivation
for the actual decrease
in the overall efficiency,
there's a few things.
One, remember your
maximum power is
your Voc times your ISC
times your fill factor.
So if you want the
derivative of your max power
with respect to
temperature, you need
to do the partial
derivatives and sum them up
for all of those
different components.
So that's what this
calculation's doing.
And again, this is what
it is for fill factor.
This is all in Martin
Green's paper down here
and also on PVCDROM if you
guys are interested in that.
Martin Green's
tabulated a lot of this,
making these general
expressions and also
fitting it to experimental
data to get that information.
And then it ends up being
not a negligible percent,
but about half a percent per
degree Celsius for silicon.
So if you go up
by 40 degrees, you
can see that temperature's a
non-negligible effect in terms
of performance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
silicon's kind
of below the ideal bandgap for
a single-junction solar cell?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you had a
semi-conductor with one that
was above that, would an
increase in temperature
increase the efficiency
because it's getting simply
closer to that bandgap?
PROFESSOR: Oh,
that's a good point.
Generally temperature's a lot
worse because you're really
going to hurt your Voc.
You would increase your J0
tremendously with temperature
because you're creating
more thermal carriers,
so your diffusion current that's
counteracting your illumination
current is going to
increase dramatically,
so temperature is
always your enemy.
There was a great
picture on PVCDROM
of a solar install in
Antarctica and its perform
well above spec,
which is kind of cool.
So yeah, temperature's
generally an enemy.
And so a lot of people's
ideas have often
been like to do active cooling
and use that for waste heat,
and there's a lot of reasons
why that doesn't necessarily
economically make sense.
But when you do, let's
say concentrated solar,
for example, and
I think Tonio will
talk about this in
the next lecture,
but concentrated solar is
you're putting in not just
one sun but about
1,000, maybe 10,000 suns
on one small device.
And the idea there is you can
have a really small device,
have it be really expensive
but incredibly efficient,
on the order of 40%
efficient because you
have these stacks of
difference semiconductors
that absorb different regions
of the light preferentially.
And those heat up tremendously
when you're being subjective.
It's like an ant under a
magnifying glass or something.
It can burn it.
So they actually active
cooling to cool those cells.
And they also have to track
the sun, as well, in order
to concentrate it.
And the last thing which you
guys did for your exam number
one was the effect of light
intensity, where you looked
at light intensity
throughout the day,
assumed some sinusoid
for the incident light,
and you measured how
your efficiency changes.
And you remember, your Voc
decreases with light intensity
with your JSC, and that's due
to the decrease in the photon
flux.
And your efficiency
goes down according
to those two equations there,
and I think the derating factor
if you assume a sinusoid
that hits at one sun
and then declines, you
should derate your--
if you use instead
of using peak sun,
you want to derate
that by about 20%.
So it's actually
pretty substantial.
I was kind of surprised
at that finding.
So when V cells go
out into the field,
they are not just
one individual cell.
So oftentimes you string these
in series and then in parallel.
So right now we're just going to
look at series and in parallel
solely, and what you see here
are your three different cells
all mounted in series.
So the top of this
cell is connected
to the bottom of this
cell, the top of this cell
is connected to the
bottom of this cell.
Our bad cell, marked here with
the I guess the denim pattern.
I don't know what that
was in PowerPoint.
But what's important
here is that
because the current
flowing to this one
is also flowing to this
one is flowing to this one,
the voltages add and the
currents are all matched.
So the current out of
this stack of cells
is limited by your weakest cell.
It can't exceed your
short-circuit current
of your weakest cell.
So you can see that your
operating point for these three
cells is not ideal for this one.
It's definitely way off
the peak operating point
for this cell and way
off the peak operating
point for that cell.
So it can be a pretty
detrimental effect,
and this is why
often in industry
when you do a series of
testing on your cells,
each cell gets tested either
using suns Voc or a very, very
fast IV measurement.
You can [? bin ?] cells
based on their performance
and then match them so that
if you all your cells are
perfectly matched, they're all
operating at the peak power
point and you're getting the
most out of all those cells.
And so that's why reducing the
variability within your process
can really, really increase
your module performance,
and that's something a
lot of companies work
really, really hard at.
Now, the other reason why
series is important to study
is the effect of shading.
So when you decrease--
so let's say
a leaf falls on your solar
panel or it's partially shaded
because you put it near trees.
If you look at the BigBelly
Solar ones right near campus,
they're always in shade.
It makes no sense to me.
I think they might get
one hour of sun a day
in certain times of the
Anyhow, And so if you partially
shade one of the
cells, you can see
that the IV curve drops
down, and now this cell
is running in reverse bias.
And when you're in reverse bias,
you're running a lot of current
through your shunts.
And for those who were
here this morning,
we know that shunts
are really, really bad
because that's where all your
current's running through.
And if your current's
running through one localized
spot, that's where it's
heating up the most,
and it can heat up to
temperatures that can actually
melt the encapsulant or
completely destroy the cell,
so this can actually
be rather destructive.
And generally once your cells
are made and encapsulated
in the module, it's really
hard to remove them and replace
that module.
Pretty much the whole
module's kaput at that point,
so it's pretty destructive.
So what people
generally do for-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in maintenance,
like yearly maintenance,
you should clean the
panel because of the dirt,
or is there any other thing
that you should do [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There's
important things.
So you don't want--
it helps if they're
angled so snow and other
things will fall off of it.
You don't want to
put it in areas
next to a chimney, for example,
where certain parts of the day
it will be shaded,
or things like that.
So I've seen some
studies on cleaning,
and it all depends on if it
economically makes sense.
If you want to pay someone
to clean your panels,
that's expensive.
Is it worth it for them
to do that if you're only
saving just a little bit?
Obviously, the shading's so
bad that it could detrimentally
ruin and destroy your module.
It's really-- you
want to do that?
Ways to prevent the destruction
is actually a lot of cells
will have bypass diodes.
So if a string goes
down, the current
will just [? flow ?]
through that diode
and won't destroy the
cell, and so that's one way
of kind of fixing that problem.
That's a great question.
So now we're stacking
ourselves in parallel.
Normally, again, in a module,
you have them in series
and then these stacks
of cells in series
are actually put in
parallel, but there's just
an easy illustration.
Again, cells in parallel,
you're matching in voltage
and the currents
are what add in.
And so if one cell let's say
has a low output voltage,
it's going to shift
the operating power
point for the other two cells
off of their maximum power
point and you're going
to get a reduced output.
And so this is actually
very analogous to this idea
that when you make
your cells larger,
generally their efficiency
and performance go down.
You have a higher chance
of inhomogeneities
and other things that might
detrimentally hurt your cell.
And this is kind of
analogous to saying
when you hook a whole
bunch of cells in parallel,
you're limited by
your worst cell.
And in this case, you're
limited by your worst
region of that
cell, and so that's
the same kind of analogy.
And I think it's kind
of cool, and so you
can see this for a lot
of different cells.
So these are actually
getting pretty big.
So when you're getting
to-- I don't know
if they make cells this big.
But it's 100 by 100.
That's a meter squared.
Wow, so maybe Cad-tel
can get that big.
Actually, they do.
Look, here's First
Solar right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
[INAUDIBLE] modules.
So some of the
cells you can see.
So here's cells--
amorphous, submodule.
Anyhow, so the idea
is that you're, again,
limited by your most
defective region in the cell.
And again, illustrated
by this idea
here is that if you take a cell,
you split it up into a grid,
and you model it as a bunch
of many cells operating
in parallel, you're again
limited by that bad region.
And so this looks
a little outdated.
So this is 2006.
So this is cell performance
versus module performance,
and you can see that it's
also quite significant.
One of the other things
that's different about cells
and modules is that you
have glass in front.
So when you optimize--
for example, in class
we optimized our
silicon nitride coating
for an air-silicon interface.
Modules, you optimize at silicon
nitride coating for a silicon
to glass interface.
And the glass, which has an
index refraction of about 1.5,
you're automatically going
to reflect 4% of the light,
so that light's lost.
But it does help with
your reflection losses
because you now have a
graded index of refraction.
So it does reduce some of
those reflection losses
from that interface.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this just silicon?
PROFESSOR: I'm guessing
yes because this
is from Richard Swanson.
This is Tonio's slide.
My guess would be yes, but
don't quote me on that.
AUDIENCE: So for the modules,
how is voltage and current
controlled?
I'm assuming that they control
it at a specific point.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so that's
a great, great question,
actually.
So your modules are
hooked up to an inverter.
The output of your solar
cells are direct current,
and so you have to convert
that to alternating current.
And the inverters are
actually rather intelligent.
They'll actually constantly scan
at a very high frequency where
it should be operating
and taking the derivative
and finding where
that optimal point is.
And so one of the other
ideas is that if you
have a bunch of
modules, usually those
are also hooked up in parallel.
And the idea is to have
instead of just one
inverter, a microinverter-- so
small inverters for each one.
So that way, each of those are
operating at the maximum power
point.
And I think problem is that
inverters are expensive
and the larger
they are, generally
the more efficient they
are and cheaper can be.
So I don't know how far
that idea's been realized,
but it's a good question.
Does that answer it?
So we have-- good,
plenty of time.
So now we're moving
onto advanced concepts,
which, again, area
that I'm working in.
Kind of exciting.
These are ideas that are
very, very high efficiency,
potentially very
low-cost, and that's
kind of the allure to them.
And they're great science
and research projects,
so they're really
exciting to be in.
So one of things that
kind of motivates
this work-- I think you guys
have seen this equation.
I know I've used it before.
But you know that the defining
metric for the performance
of a cell in terms
of its economic cost
is dollars per watt, so
dollars per watt peak.
This is all defined at
your peak sun elimination.
This makes it
location-blind, right?
The really important thing when
integrating it onto the grid
is how much are you
paying in terms of cents
per kilowatt hour.
But to make it
location-blind, you
put it into dollars per
watt, and dollars per watt
is a function of many things.
It's how much does it cost
to make the module itself?
So how many dollars
per given area?
You divide it by the insulation.
For dollars per
watt peak, you'd set
that to aim 1.5 or 1,000
kilowatts per meter squared.
Multiply that times
your efficiency,
and then by your yield, which
is a manufacturing parameter.
So for some cells where if you
can reduce this number quite
dramatically, so
for example, suppose
you decide to go to very,
very thin wafers for silicon.
You want to move to 20 micron
wafers, let's say, which
is something that a lot of
companies now are working on.
What happens is that those
become very, very fragile.
And when you handle them and
using all these pick and place
operations to move them
to different processes
within the cell fab,
oftentimes they'll break.
And so that yield parameter
can come very important
and [INAUDIBLE] interplayed
with this number here,
and that's why it's there.
So anyhow, what this
graph is is this
is the dollars
per meter squared,
so the cost of
producing that cell.
And then you have
this efficiency here,
and each of these
lines represents
a certain dollars per watt.
And so I think the DOE has
wanted us to get to $1.00 per
watt, and you can do that by
either producing incredibly
efficient cells, around
50%, which seems a little
unreasonable.
And they can cost $500
per meter squared,
and that would be
actually a cheap panel.
Or the other idea is to go to
very, very low cost and low
efficiency, and you can try
to hover around in here.
And so this nomenclature
I'm about to use
is a little outdated, but I
think still some people use it,
although rather loosely.
What's known as
first-generation-- and again,
these terms I've
read papers now they
claim that they're
third-generation where
they used to be classified
as second-generation.
It doesn't really matter,
but the ideas behind them
are still relevant.
So the first-generation
with the single bandgap,
it's crystalline silicon still
[INAUDIBLE] the market leader,
and they're on the order
of 15% to 20% efficient,
but they're still
relatively high-cost.
And there's actually
a lot of work
now that says that this
can move in this direction,
moving to thinner wafers,
increased laser processing.
Just tighter manufacturing can
really bring that cost down.
So your second-generation
are your thin film.
So this is either CIGS,
amorphous silicon, organics.
A lot of these very, very
cheap to deposit, cheap
to manufacture,
but they generally
suffer in efficiency, so they
hover around in this area.
And so far, this
idea hasn't really
fulfilled itself except
for maybe cad-tel,
which is a thin film material.
And then what we're
about to talk about
is our third
generation of cells.
So these are potentially
low-cost and potentially
incredibly efficient.
So we're going to talk about
only a few types today.
I encourage you to look up.
There's a whole different types
of solar cells you can look up,
ideas, research being done.
But I'm going talk--
this is what I work on,
our intermediate-band
solar cells, specifically
impurity-band photovoltaics.
And I'm sure you're all
familiar with this picture,
but if you want to create
free mobile charges
within your
semiconductor, you have
to shine light on
it that has energies
greater than the bandgap.
And so you lose these
low-energy photons.
They're not collected,
and what's a way
that we can collect these?
Well, one idea this
guy had was if you
can create a material that
has a density of states that
looks like this, you can
create a stepping stone
by putting a half-filled
band within your bandgap that
allows you to promote to that
band and then from that band
into the conduction band.
So the idea is that your
voltage output can still
be maintained for
the host material,
but you can collect
that extra current.
So your ISC will
increase substantially,
and so that's the promise.
And if you do some theoretical
calculations similar
what Shockley and Queisser did,
assuming the radiative lifetime
is your limiting
factor-- and again,
that's certainly not the case
in some of the materials that
are worked on for this
idea-- and the idea
is you can actually get up
to around 63% efficient.
And so what this graph is here,
here's your single gap limit.
This is a calculation similar to
what Shockley and Queisser did.
I think this is using
blackbody radiation, which is
why the curves are so smooth.
And it can actually
outperform a tandem cell,
which is again a
multi-junction cell that
are two cells stacked.
And it turns out the
best is something
that has a gap level
that's about 0.7 EV
from the conduction band and
has a larger band gap, so
that distance between
your valence band
and your conduction band of
around 1.9 electron volts,
and that's kind of
the ideal material
for an intermediate-band
solar cell.
So theoretically, this
idea is a great idea.
Problem is, how do you
make a material that
has this band structure?
And that's really
the challenge where
people are working right
now, and it's actually
rather difficult. And so
there's three approaches.
One is the impurity
band, which I personally
like because it's a
much cheaper method.
Other one is this band
anti-crossing idea
where you can actually
split the conduction band,
and it's generally done with
these mixed metal oxides
and these highly
mismatched alloys,
and they're really cool.
And this is currently the
most successful material there
for intermediate-band
solar cells.
And then there's quantum dot
arrays and quantum structures
that are also a possible
fabrication method.
OK, so idea behind an
impurity photovoltaic
is you start with let's
say a material like silicon
or some other high-bandgap
gap semiconductor,
you put in impurities that
have these deep-level states.
Iron would be an example.
So iron in very
low concentrations
can be incredibly detrimental.
But as you increase
that concentration
above some critical
limit often called
the [INAUDIBLE]
transition limit,
you can actually form a
band within the bandgap.
And so the idea what's going
on here is that each of atoms
this has some
electron wave function
and some radius that it sees.
And then as you increase
that concentration,
these wave functions
overlap and you
can have conduction through
those mid-level states.
So that's one
idea, and I like it
because you use what I could
consider very dirty materials.
The concentrations
you can put in here
around are one atomic percent,
so your silicon's only 99.9%
pure at this point.
Other idea is to use either
quantum dots or these quantum
wells.
So I think the idea here
is that these are localized
and then this
becomes delocalized.
So as you bring these quantum
well structures or quantum dots
closer together,
you can actually
get tunneling
through these states,
and it basically
essentially forms
a band within your bandgap.
Similar idea is to
do this locally--
is that you have
one photon promote
to one of these confined states
in your quantum structure,
and then another photon
to keep promoting up
into your conduction
band to create carriers.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
would there
be quantum [INAUDIBLE]
embedded in the silicon,
or these are solar cells
made out of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's usually stacked
between two other semiconductor
materials.
So you have semiconductor,
quantum dot, semiconductor.
If you look up this paper
among-- if you look up
anything-- so Antonio
Luque-- sorry, yeah.
Luque and Marti are
two people in Spain
who've kind of promoted a lot
of the theory around this.
And look up their
quantum dot papers,
and they'll really go
into the device structure
if you're curious.
I'd recommend doing that, Joel.
AUDIENCE: So the x-axis
on these figures are--
PROFESSOR: Real space.
AUDIENCE: So there will be
some portions of the device
where this is possible in--
it kind of depends upon
how many quantum
wells you actually
put into your structure.
PROFESSOR: Right, and that's
one of limiting things,
is the EQE of these devices
because they can't grow
so many are pretty limited.
And again, these
also provide pathways
for traps and
other things, which
is again a huge problem
for these types of devices
and ideas.
And people are
working on that quite
extensively from the theory side
and from the experimental side,
and trying to merge the two.
OK.
Sorry, Ben?
AUDIENCE: The quantum
well [INAUDIBLE]
on the right, where
[INAUDIBLE] functions
don't overlap, do those act
as recombination centers?
PROFESSOR: It seems to me
that they would act as traps.
Again, I'm not an expert on
these types of materials,
but that would be
my inclination.
I guess the idea is that you
have a very, very short well
and then you have
a field across it
so there's not something
else to hop to.
And it just pulls it
right out, so that
would be one device structure.
Again, these are generally
just like a few layers
of quantum dots.
Oh, I didn't put
up the [INAUDIBLE].
So this is the
band-anticrossing model.
So this is they're using
these quaternary alloys.
So these are, again,
very, very hard to grow,
and they've done these
awesome measurements
where they can show your
valence band, conduction
band, and your impurity
bands, and they're
using a technique called
photomoduled reflectance,
so basically the reflectance
under oscillating fields.
And from that, you
can get these kind
of resonance points between
the different transitions
and you can figure out
where your energy state lie.
It's a really cool technique.
But what they did is
they've done some very, very
careful engineering and grown
these very, very carefully.
And they can
actually demonstrate
the sub-bandgap response
where if they have,
let's say a photon that's
able to drive this transition
but it's too low in energy
to drive that transition,
they will get no current out.
And then as soon as
they add the higher one,
the current will increase.
And then if they turn off
that low-energy photon source,
the current
decreases but doesn't
stop because the other
high-energy photon can
do both promotions.
So this is actually one of
the only successful devices
of impurity-band
solar cells, and it
was quite an awesome feat.
So I think one of
the few ones we'll
talk about for another advanced
concept is hot carrier cells.
This is something I think
Martin Green pioneered,
and I believe it
still working on.
I haven't heard much
about them recently,
so I don't know what
the progress is there.
So the idea is that one
of the biggest losses,
as I'm sure you guys know
from I think homework 1 or 2,
is thermalization
in your solar cells.
When you promote an electron
well up into the conduction
band, it then gives
off heat or phonons,
which are just lattice
vibrations, which
is another way of
thinking about heat.
In that process, the problem
is that's incredibly fast.
If you look at the
time scales here,
so you come and you promote
this electron way up
into your conduction band.
This is what it looks like
prior at that promotion,
and then it slowly decays,
and that decay happens over
about a picosecond.
So if you want to move your
carrier in a picosecond,
if you know what
your field is, you
can see how long that length
is, and that length scale
is also incredibly short.
And so one of the ideas
is, OK, how either we
can decrease our path
length, or we can somehow
slow down thermalization,
and that's actually one idea.
And to slow down
thermalization is something
that they call carrier cooling.
And basically making certain
types of device structures
or material structures, you can
inhibit certain phonon modes.
So when these
electrons get promoted,
they want to give off heat.
They basically give
off lattice vibrations,
so they want to shake
the atoms around them
and distribute that motion.
If you prevent that
from happening somehow,
through certain
types of structures,
you can allow that
process to go slower,
and that's one of the ideas.
Extracting the carriers--
also kind of difficult.
You need to have contacts
that are selective that
can take the hot carriers at
all the different energies
that they're promoted
at, and that's
also a really difficult idea.
And some of the ideas that
they've been working on
are these resonant
tunneling contacts.
So again, this is
kind of hairy stuff.
I think these slides
are rather old
and I don't know what's
come of this research.
So it's a really exciting
idea and I encourage
you guys to look more into it.
OK, so now we're going
to move a little bit away
from advanced concepts and talk
about kind of bulk thin film
materials, and I
think we're actually
going to end quite
early, which is fine.
So the most common
commercially-available type
of material are these
wafer-based materials,
so monocrystalline,
which you know,
which is what our
cells are made of.
This CZ, or Czochralski
growth, probably
pronouncing that wrong.
Silicon,
multichrystalline silicon,
which I think Tonio was showing
you what that looks like.
You can see the
different grains.
They're actually quite pretty.
Ribbon silicon, which was
pioneered by Evergreen,
and I think now that
technology's gone.
Evergreen went out of
business, so I don't think
that technology's still around.
The [INAUDIBLE] still
might be making modules.
Anyhow, so thin films.
Cad-tel is still
currently-- or First Solar
is still one of the
cheapest module makers.
Their process was so cheap
that their efficiency really
suffered because
they didn't even
have an ARC coating for
the first 5 or 10 years
of development.
And they said we didn't need
it, and they were right.
They were still
outperforming silicon people.
That's becoming less so the
case and one of the big problems
with Cad-tel, as you guys
know, is the [INAUDIBLE]
and also the toxicity,
which some people are
really concerned about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just a note on that.
So if we're debating
in this class
whether the should be allowed
to be imported into Japan.
And my understanding,
from the reading,
was that Japan actually does
not allow cadmium telluride
imports.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: I guess so, then yes.
I don't actually know.
I do know that Cad-tel
is a very stable compound
and I know people
who work with it here
and they actually
work on recycling it,
so how to dissolve it and
separate the two elements.
And they're not worried
about the hazards
of the actual raw
material because it's
a pretty stable compound, but a
lot of people do worry about it
and it's certainly
a valid concern.
But one of the thin film
replacements, well amorphic
silicon-- you think
you guys know that is,
but that's deposited silicon.
It has no real like lattice
structure to speak of.
It's kind of a disordered
mess, which means
it has a lot of dangling bonds.
It has very, very low
lifetimes as a result,
and also in [INAUDIBLE]
low mobilities.
You also deposit it and
you deposit with hydrogen
to passivate all of
those dangling bonds,
and that's usually done with
either plasma-enhanced chemical
vapor deposition, and it's
done on either metal or glass.
And so it has the
potential to be very cheap.
And then one of
things I think was
aimed to replace Cad-tel
was CIGS-- so copper,
indium, gallium, diselenide.
I'll get to some of the
problems with CIGS in a second,
but there are few
startups around it.
I think Nanosolar
is one, HelioVolt,
and I think Solyndra was one,
although I don't really want
to say their name out loud.
So problem with
CIGS is if you're
looking for
Earth-abundant films,
again if we want to scale-- if
we want solar energy to scale
to terawatt levels, if
we want it to provide all
of human energy
needs-- then we're
going to need to use
elements and materials
that are Earth-abundant, cheap
to find, cheap to produce,
and CIGS isn't going
to get us there.
It's got indium and gallium.
Indium, which is highly
used and the price
has skyrocketed
now because I think
it's used in your
displays and televisions.
There's indium in here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so that's
where it comes from then.
Thank you.
So what people have
been working or trying
to look at replacements--
so this is CZTS.
So it's copper, zinc, tin,
it's sometimes sulfide.
This is selenide,
but they are also
working on replacing the
selenium with sulfur, something
a little more Earth-abundant.
And this was done at IBM and
it was pretty remarkable,
actually, because I think
within a very, very short period
of time, they were able
to get efficiencies
around 9.6%, which for
a fledgling material
is incredible, and
I'll get to why that
was so incredible in a second.
But again, when thinking about
Earth-abundant materials,
I really recommend you
guys read this paper.
This is a paper by Cyrus Wadia.
It's "Environmental
Science and Technology"
and it looks all of these
different semiconductor
materials and it
looks at in yellow,
this is what you
could get if you
look at annual production of
that semiconductor material
now in terms of what is
being produced to produce
the raw materials that make it.
And then the known
economic reserves,
what can we mine and
get economically today,
how much could it produce?
And your worldwide
consumption is on this line,
and you can see Cad-tel is
just barely eking it out.
And the ones of note
for this discussion
are Cad-tel, CIGS, which
is slightly better,
and then CZTS, which is
rather plentiful even
with reserves that are
currently being mined now,
and so that's kind of
the take-home message.
The other thing also
really interesting
is the actual raw material cost.
Cad-tel, turns out,
it's not that great
when you compare it
to CIGS and then CZTS.
It's a whole lot cheaper.
So one of the other things
about CZTS that's so cool
is that there's basically
this huge growth parameter
space for making these
quaternary alloys,
and IBM on their first shot
just kind of nailed it.
So they didn't really look at
this whole parameter space.
It was just kind of their
first shot was right there,
and so it might already be
optimized, and a lot of people
are kind of
concerned about that.
But I think it's certainly
a very interesting field
and really cool to
work in, so I think
hopefully there's hope here.
So actually we're
ending way early,
but that concludes
the lecture today.
If you guys want to stick
around for more questions,
that's totally fine, but that's
all I had prepared for today.
So thank you.